we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P you can call any time of
day here is our old friend Juan calling
in to say David you're wrong California
is a disaster listen to this David sir
you're talking a lot of BS when it comes
to Gavin Newsom really
and the reason I say that is because
let's see California
right
how have you solved
the tents on the roads did Gavin Newsom
claim he solved homelessness I didn't
hear him claim that in his interview
with Sean Hannity the turds on the
sidewalks the stents
in the public areas where the homeless
are
he hasn't done anything with that or at
least many complaints that exist about
that
um
when he actually solves it 100 percent
then you could say okay all right so he
did solve it but he hadn't solved it so
first of all is the new standard that no
state can be considered successful if
there's any homelessness well then there
are no successful states in the United
States there's homelessness in every
state that I'm aware of I know Wyoming
only has like 500 000 people I think
there are still homeless people even in
Wyoming okay so if that's the standard
then then we can't judge any state
because every state has some
homelessness I am not like a California
um
acolyte or like a fan you know as I've
said before I've been to a number of U.S
states they almost all have good things
and things that are not so good it can't
be denied
that California's economy is one of the
most dynamic in the world if California
were a country it would be one of the
most powerful economies by itself in the
world the amount of innovation the
number of Nobel laureates the amount of
groundbreaking research in Tech and
medicine that is coming out of
California it's not coming out of I'm
not gonna you know put any particular
State on blast but it's not coming out
of a lot of other states California
operating with a budget surplus it is
expensive in California that's because
of that free market that right-wingers
love
uh California's state income tax is
Progressive and it goes all the way up
to 13 if you pay 37 percent federally
and 13 in California that's 50 and then
you add property taxes and properties
are expensive in California I'm not
denying it's expensive part of the
reason it's expensive is because there's
not enough housing part of the reason
it's expensive is because a lot of
people want to live there uh
homelessness it's a major problem part
of the reason that homelessness is a
problem in California
uh is the weather is good and it's a
safe place if you have no home
that if you're stuck outside you're not
going to freeze to death in I don't
think just about any part of California
you could go up in the hills to ski
resorts I don't think that's where the
homeless people are so there are
criticisms of California but this idea
that there is a California Exodus
because of woke High tax California and
it's failing and all these different
things it is simply not the case I've
never lived in California I don't intend
to I have no personal uh horse in this
race but that is the reality we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com I want to see you
there and we will be back with a new
program tomorrow as well